my name is Erin Bruner i'm i'm the third
of the set of lectures from CI i'm going
to talk a bit about the potential
utility of looking at protected areas
from an economic perspective you all are
probably quite familiar with the fairly
rancorous debate around protected areas
with people on one side calling for
fifty percent of the earth to be covered
in protected areas and people on the
other talking about conservation has a
major source of psychological refugees
I'm big economic claims somewhere in the
middle and what I'm going to try to do
is is talk a bit about how a more
rational economic look at protected
areas can offer some insight into how
how to think about particular areas
thank you as a way to promote the public
good for various reasons and I get into
what I mean by how do i how do I advance
not good all right I'm going to do four
things the first is to fairly briefly
give a bit of a justification for why it
might be useful to use economics to
think about predicted areas the majority
of the talk will be based on looking at
to sort of technical issues and the
implications they have the first of
those is comparison to benefit the costs
how you do it and what kind of comes out
of thinking about it like that and the
second one is issue of market failure
and the implications of that for
protected area strategies and I'll end
very briefly by talking a bit about some
of the potentially important themes that
this suggests going forward as you're
all aware protected areas over time have
been created for quite a broad number of
reasons those range from clean water
provision to tourism to to simply
protecting the natural heritage of a
place for for our kids or for our
grandkids at the same time protect areas
have also in many cases been opposed by
somebody and this is certainly the case
in the air protected areas since since
they've gone from being simple taboo
sites or sacred groves to a management
structure that crosses multiple people
multiple interests multiple rights and
it's worth noting that that's quite
simply I think because they have costs
those include the direct cost of
predicted air management they include
the cost often of human wildlife
conflict and the challenge of having to
stop killing something that's eating
your crotch is not
it should be overlooked the include
issues like lost access to natural
resources although there's a
sustainability question in there that we
should get into a bit they have included
certainly issues of displacement and
that there are sort of horrific cases of
people being displaced from protected
areas now and then they include in every
case just like with any resource
decision a forgone opportunity an
opportunity cost that is what you can't
do with the area because you're
protecting it yeah and I've included I
think you can see it but I served a
cover shot of a neat paper by Paul
Ferraro and Laura Taylor on the subject
of opportunity costs which is kind of a
quick and fun read about about that and
how economists don't understand it well
enough um and the point to bring out
here is that if you look at for example
given protected area and you look at the
actors that benefit from it and pay for
it at different scales say a local scale
and national scale on a global scale the
benefits and the costs they each receive
are very different so that these are
just illustrative but you can see that
they aren't the same and a couple of
really important generalities can be
drawn out of this the first is that very
often costs are focused while benefits
are dispersed the classic served case
this would be carbon Community or
government has to pay the opportunity
cost of not using a forest for logging
or for agriculture if they want to
protect the carbon value that's some of
the global community benefits from
another another sort of common
generality here is that costs are often
short term while benefits are longer
term this would be the case for example
in creating a marine protected area to
manage fisheries we're asking in that
case for fishermen to forego a catch in
the present presumably for a greater
catch in the future and the final
perhaps not so common but important
generality to draw it is it coughs costs
every often quite a bit more palpable
than the benefits so if a lion kills
your cow and it's one of your three cows
or if monkey eats your crop that's an
immediate fiasco and it's much more
palpable even if the value in economic
terms is sort of the same then all the
little bees that are fertilizing the
grass that the cow eats and all the
beetles that are digesting the nitrogen
so anyway so and so it's perceived
differently even if the sort of economic
number adds up and what economics offers
is a way to sort of dissect all that
not just to understand the numbers and
how they stack up and how they're
perceived how they play out over time
which one's come through the market and
to understand how to deal with that that
reality so so jumping to the first of
these technical themes I mentioned that
there were two I'll talk first a bit
about this issue of how to do how to do
a serve a fair valuation of benefits to
cost for protected areas and then I'll
review some of the sort of headline
numbers that come out of doing that from
the team report from the technical side
I think maybe I'll emphasize two points
there are probably others but but the
first somewhat obviously isn't need to
compare comparable things this is
somewhat easier in a sight scale where
it's possible in people I've done this
in a few cases to look at benefits and
costs together in the same place that is
where the people are the same the
alternatives are the same the change in
the deforestation rate that you're going
to achieve through protection is the
same that's a good way to generate a
truly comparable number taking that from
a site to say a national scale is
challenging if you don't have a
representative sample of the sites in
the country and there are places where
that exists and so people looking to do
more global things or more national
things I've done a bit of using the site
and guessing about how to extrapolates
but also the second thing which is to
look at summer your average values not
necessarily from the same place but with
the idea if you take enough from enough
places you perhaps overcome some of the
bias of just taking kind of one costs
from one place in one benefit from
another and i'll give you examples of
each of these as we go along and the
final thing and i think this is quite
worth noting is to learn from what's
already happened that is that is to look
at how well-off people are in and around
protected areas versus not in around
protected areas and control for other
things like market access and so rather
than going through the survey comics of
what benefits and what costs are there
just try to understand the state and the
outcome and there's something to be
learned from that as well um the second
service set of points here is the
importance of working at the margin and
I don't know how many of your economists
but I I mean that in the economic sense
of the word that is the the difference
in for example a certain amount of
investment to protect the area the
marginal difference of adding one more
unit of that or taking it away rather
than something that's sort of working on
something that's irrelevant which is
maybe the comment
standing of that word and in that area
are sort of three points to add 11 is
the need to be careful extrapolating the
thing that got some of the people's
hackles raised when Bob Costanza
published his sort of seminal work in
1997 about this about ecosystems
services was that he'd extrapolated from
site specific values to sum total of
areas that might include that might have
those services so say from one kilometer
of beach which may have a 50-dollar
value of tourism to all the beach in all
the world which should have fifty fifty
dollars times the total number and then
there's a potential error there because
those services can go up or down
depending on how the pattern looks now
the second point to start bringing out
here in regard to the margin is a need
to include echo system services from the
productive landscapes one of the sort of
easy things to overlook is that is to
sort of say protected areas have the
following ecosystem services and
production landscapes of the following
production and that's the comparison but
in reality there's quite a bit of value
of ecosystems service from production
landscapes as well and it's important to
take that into account and the final
point here I think is at the very least
to be transparent about the difference
between total and marginal value I have
served bias here about thing that total
value is actually a sort of a deceptive
thing to say and it all but but to very
least be transparent about it and just
to sort break that down a bit total
value of a protected area as you know
could be broken apart into a bunch of
pieces perhaps extraction of some forest
products perhaps recreation perhaps
downstream water services perhaps a
biodiversity conservation them you could
categorize those according to their
piece of Toad economic value or to the
type of echo system service they are and
if you do that come up with that total
number you can make a statement about
how much protected areas are
contributing to Social Welfare what you
can't do with that statement is say it's
good to invest in protected areas
because you don't know that you don't
know whether your investment would
change the flow of benefits you don't
know what would happen to the other
sorts of service services and other
sources are well being from that
landscape to do that you need to go a
step farther and you need to get towards
marginal value marginal again meaning
incremental not
not irrelevant and so you can
potentially learn about a couple of
different things here first to
understand what would happen to
landscape without your intervention and
hypothetically here services would go
down that's the value of degradation and
that tells us whether there's something
to worry about in the first place if
nothing would happen if you didn't
invest there's pretty little
justification for investing so author is
also worth understanding what would
happen if you did invest that is
presumably again in this hypothetical
case and increase in values of some
kinds at least an associated costs which
showed up on the bottom that's the value
of conservation it's it's the net of
those two things that can tell you
whether conservation is a good
investment again a marginal thing not a
total thing and just to sort of belabor
this point a bit if you have benefits in
the future without conservation benefits
in the future with conservation you can
start to break apart the net change that
is some services will go up recreation
in this case water services in this case
value of biodiversity conservation
itself some things will go down in this
case there may be less extraction from
forest products and there'll be some
direct costs in this case the cost of
management and it's that net of the
gross benefits of Conservation minus the
opportunity cost minus the costs that
lets you say not only as conservation a
good thing we can invest in it has a
positive return but it's better than the
alternative and that ultimately is the
thing that's most useful to decision
makers and I won't belabor this point
too much but but it's worth noting this
is a more complex thing to do it
requires you to know changes what
happens to ecosystem as you invest more
what happens to serve as flow as a
system changes what happens the other
thing is coming from that system as you
improve the conservation and that's a
more data intensive thing unless you
make quite a bit of assumption and I'll
leave that there but if there are
questions we can come back to it um so
with it with that sort of background
I'll review now bit the the sort of
headline numbers again coming out of
team and a few other places at the sort
of global national and local scale the
first number the one that serves still
most commonly cited at the global scale
is one that's now almost ten years old
that's from from Andrew bonford and a
few other people who costed two things
they costed an expanded predicted air
system that's where my Alex James now
also very old and they estimated
benefits of that system based on per
hectare values from Bob Costanza the
same ones that were criticized they made
an adjustment to that to deal with this
marginal issue which was to look at all
the studies that existed at that time
which are about five I think that
compared benefits of conservation and
benefits of production in the same place
and made sure to include the ecosystem
valley service value production as well
so that is addressed that piece of the
margin not make the area of assuming
that there's no value of service and
production landscapes and they found
that ratio of something like two to one
is they adjusted down the total value
benefits from nine billion nine sorry
nine trillion down to about four that's
where they made that correction the the
other issue of marginality extrapolating
from a marginal value to a whole wasn't
addressed here we took another swing at
this antibes using basically newer data
from the stern report and Teebs updated
the per hectare values on average and
came out in developing countries in the
areas of active deforestation with about
25 to 1 as the ratio of benefit that
cost so so probably just to do avoids
are skipping over this a logical
question what could be you know is it
was it reasonable these things could
coexist together and be different and I
think probably there's two two ways to
think about that one would be to say
that neither one is attempting to be
correct they're both sort of
generalizations from brought data and so
in that context to me they're actually
not that far off even though they're
there they're different from each other
they're both making the general case so
this is a good investment and the other
would be to say that protected areas has
been served revealed by a bunch of
research in the past decade are
preferentially located out of areas of
active deforestation that is where the
opportunity cost is lower and that too
would imply that the cost-benefit ratio
would be would be higher in areas of
active deforestation anyway so something
to think about in thinking about whether
those are reasonably can reasonably
exist together so moving to the national
scale I you can do two things here and I
and I thought about this a bit one of
them is to sort of adjust those bompard
at all numbers
to take out the piece of the benefits
that's global and we did some of that 40
but I think I think probably the more
useful way to think about this is to say
that that doing that suggested this is
still probably a good investment on
average but as you get anywhere away
from the global scale I think it's much
more useful to sort of think about case
evidence and think about particular
cases it doesn't do a hell of a lot of
good to say on average countries are
this much better off if they have a
protected area system because they need
their actual data and so I'll just
review a couple of cases and again
that's the part we can come back to if
anyone's interested in one is I think
quite a pioneering study by by Jean
Kristoff cafe and in Madagascar which
looked at that at an expansion the
national protected area system basically
the hilltops remaining forest types and
found that for the country investment in
protected area would generate a fifty
percent return above the costs and that
would come in in the form of water
avoided damage to irrigated agriculture
down the slopes increased international
payment for the protected area system a
big assumption but but part of this
analysis and I'm not sure what else and
cost on the other hand would come in
terms of foregone agricultural expansion
of the hills some similar work was done
in Scotland this is costing the nut to
or a 2000 targets which you guys may
know of those are basically the European
Union's set of sort of joint targets for
any degree to protected area system this
work and Scotland found that that the
benefit to the Scottish public not
globally because that's higher but the
benefit to the Scottish public was about
three times higher than the investment
that's a little scotland again so a
positive cost-benefit ratio but and
there is a but here that there in the
example at the bottom actually is a case
example from a site rather than a
national study but but it's relevant
there are other cases where if you take
out the piece of benefits that are
global and no one pays for them then you
get a flop and it becomes not in the
national best interest to do protected
areas the major benefit type in the
analysis impaired why the by far and
away was a carbon value and if you
remove that from the analysis far and
away agriculture becomes a better choice
for paraguay and that gets the issue
whether or not people are actually
paying for these services that benefit
the global community and I'll get into
that too at the local scale I think it's
fair to say that generalizations are
probably even less useful and the reason
why is if you look at again at this
chart if you look at what kinds of
benefits and what kinds of costs could
accrue to local actors whether they be
the maintenance of is the sort of
sustainability of consumptive resource
uses whether they be a whole other set
of potential local ecosystem services
whether they be cultural and spiritual
values on the benefit side and on the
cost side the whole set practically are
possible all of them are dependent on
where protected areas go and how they're
managed and so I think again sort of
making it trying to make a generic
statement about particular it'd be a
good thing locally or a bad thing
locally is perhaps less useful than
simply trying to understand how we can
make sure that we tip the balance so
that benefits are greater than costs and
that I think is probably a good segue to
the second bit of this talk um but
before I do that I started wanted to
pause I I'm conscious of talking at you
guys too much and also it may be a good
spot for questions is there any is there
any clarifying questions about that that
would be useful before we go to the rest
and if they reflect the last part of the
lecture I'll just keep going but but if
there are any questions I'd be happy to
try to address them or not
okay all right good okay um so so like I
said the that issue of that issue of
sort of working on trying to make sure
benefits are greater than costs is a
good segue to this issue of market
failure and that's the second bit of the
talk market failure its implications for
protected area strategies or the second
substantive bit the theoretical basis
for this as you guys probably know is
that markets function well as a as a
system for allocating among scarce
things in some contexts they function
really well for producers deciding how
to produce something they function
really well in the hypothetical example
of someone choosing between buying
another t-shirt another candy bar they
function poorly in the case of many
environmental issues and not just
environmental she'd spent a lot of other
social issues as well and that's that's
a broad field but some of the most
relevant reasons why that happens are
listed here and I'll actually go into
these in some detail and the rest but
just to sort of start off inadequate
information for example if you're a
farmer and you don't know that bees help
pollinate your crop or you don't know
the value of it and you don't know that
they live in the forest fringe that
you've kept because it's served rocky
and not fertile you don't manage for
that it doesn't enter into your sort of
calculation about how you're going to
use your land and as a result you make a
decision typically which is to clear
that when win and if that becomes
economically viable independent of
whether or not your crop production is
going to suffer because you don't know
consumers can also sort of have
information failures some really neat
workers done by Ian Bateman his
colleagues studying whether people would
be willing to pay more for oil palm for
their margarine i think in that case for
oil palm products if they knew that it
that it protected tigers better and
found that they would and the point
there is that consumers don't know that
by and large they don't know that their
margarine has a negative impact on
tigers and because they don't know that
they don't pay more even though they do
willing to pay more and because of that
the people in a position to produce
don't produce that way if they don't get
a price premium for it another
information failure and just a sort of
offer you perhaps a less intuitive one
Australia as some of you might know it
has been quite keen to start an industry
in kangaroo meat export that's something
that the world has been quite negative
on and the reason is because because oh
my god we can't eat kangaroos they're
these beautiful things but that that
turns out to be quite information
failure because kangaroos are very well
suited to Australia they can be managed
sustainably the meat is healthy
Australia has great working models for
how to manage kangaroos you have are you
from Australia my office meters from
Australia and that's where this came
from but anyway and the result of that
though is that Australia then ends up
stalking its range land with other
things that are much less well suited to
the ecosystem they have a big negative
impact and again it's it's a it's an
information failure because people sort
of think oh no horrible did horrible
disaster the Kangaroos to eat them end
up with this bad feedback that affects
ultimately resource uses isn't the
second sort of second type of market
failure that I'll that I'll get into a
bit and I won't talk about near match
one to flag it is this issue of poorly
defined we're not enforceable property
rice this this gets quite a bit to the
issue the commons which is one that I
won't talk about it's covered much more
effectively by other people but but
there are a few issues that i want to
bring out so i'm just flagging it now
and the last one is to talk a bit about
externalities and public goods negative
externalities being make sure I get this
right being damage done by by people who
don't pay the cost for it and positive
externalities being being cases where
potential providers of a positive thing
aren't sharing the benefit of it both of
those things sort of systematically
result in over under production of the
thing and public goods being being those
which people can either be excluded from
nor northern or which my enjoyment of
them can exclude other people's
enjoyment of them or diminishes and the
closet characteristic of a public good
is that you'd be free ride a very little
real incentive to pay because your piece
of the investment is small you don't
perceive that your investment will have
a marginal difference and that's the
case of everything from sort of service
in the Army to clean air and certainly
the case for many environmental goods
& services-karbonn being an obvious
example although that's not sort of
being addressed to some degree as I
serve a major next negative externality
around the world an existence value of
biodiversity the thing which many
conservation groups have been served
most concerned with even if they weren't
using the economic term that too is in
many ways a public good and one which
people are over time very unwilling to
kind of continually pay for even if they
like the idea of it looking at protected
areas like this offers I think a really
interesting opportunity to tie into it
what's actually quite a well-developed
sore a bit of thinking on with an
accepted terminology and in fact
acceptance theoretically across quite a
wide spectrum of people ranging from
frail eco servers fairly liberal and in
particular it offers two things to us I
think that a really useful one is a
standard set of intervention types as
well as justification for them an
understanding of how to apply them to
deal with to deal with problems those
are regulations tax subsidies and market
creation I'll get into relevant examples
in a minute and they also offer and I
think this is really interesting some
sort of a checklist to double-check the
logic of our interventions so thinking
about what market failures might be at
play in a given place is potentially
really useful at classic error might be
to say look I know echo system services
are important i'm going to enter this
place and provide a lot of information
and by demonstrating that the place is
important conservation will happen but
if you don't think about for example
externalities are public goods and
people transacting the values where the
benefits and costs are in different
places the thing doesn't work so again
perhaps just useful check us to keep in
mind i'm going to now go through
actually each one of these market
failures and give a few examples of sort
of work that's been done to deal with
them and i think it's probably worth the
caveat that these aren't necessarily the
best technically examples of doing this
that their chosen to bring out key
issues more than anything else so there
may be some technical issues that you
want to point out but the the idea is to
use them to serve tease out things that
should be considered in the area of
improving information and these are
these are actually the results of this
study by currently a that i mentioned
before from madagascar I think we
unavoidably need to be talking about
valuation but not just valuation also
trade-offs that is again that marginal
issue protected areas are good but are
they better than the next thing you need
to know that too and you also need to
know about distribution of benefits and
costs and even just sort of a quick look
at how this shakes out makes pretty
clear that there's a major problem
brewing here so even though a protected
area system expansion might be a good
thing even for Madagascar as a whole
which is perhaps the level at which the
president is thinking about it as he
talks not the president now president at
the time as he talks about an expansion
there's a major group here that
potentially suffers a huge loss and
that's the poorest group of people in
the country that's the slash-and-burn
farmers that are going to become
prohibited from moving up slope into
what are actually quite marginal areas
for agriculture but the only thing they
have because of their agricultural form
so so information to be aware of and
also to have to deal with if you want
both an equitable sort of result and an
effective particular area system I
thought I'd take a little bit of time to
talk in a bit of detail about about one
analysis looking at sort of cost
benefits of a particular expansion and
as I said this this isn't one of the
best technically but it covers the
issues this is done by a couple of
colleagues and it and it's the
cost-benefit analysis of a protected
area expansion in the Atlantic forest
done fairly quickly done to sort of just
get a sense of the issues for those of
you that don't know this is this is a
relatively wealthy area especially
especially in the sort of developing
country context and it's one that's
quite heavily fragmented something like
seven percent of the Atlantic forest
original cover is intact that is there's
quite a lot of agricultural production
quite a big need for reforestation and
that's another piece of this scenario
that I'm not going to get into so what
was done here was to break this out into
two scenarios again like I mentioned to
try to work a bit at the margin one sort
of business as usual scenario that is no
protective no new protected areas and
one new one one sort of green scenario
green development being the sort of term
that was in use of the time which
comprised itself a 22 new or expanded
protected areas and the key sort of
driver for the marginal difference in
benefits and costs of this is a change
in the historical deforestation rate
historical deforestation right here was
about forty three percent there's
obvious mistakes in simply assuming
that's the rate that will continue to
the future but that what was done for
this purpose and and what was assumed
then was that predicted arias would
would decrease that by some amount that
too is an assumption there there's no
sort of rule floating around for how
much protected areas decreased
deforestation for a given amount of
investment an area for future work
certainly but I think maybe just sort of
driven on driven on case examples driven
on some rigorous studies that try to be
sort of careful their methodology it's
not unrealistic I think that a
well-managed high-profile system of
protected areas could reduce
deforestation by 75% anyway we can talk
about that too if someone wants a whole
range of data collected critically for
this purpose agricultural data forestry
data livestock data to try to understand
opportunity costs carbon density data
relevant to some of the environmental
values this is sort of the framework for
analysis actually I'd I wouldn't
necessarily tend to do it like this but
it doesn't particularly matter the point
is to sort of break apart the potential
benefits and the potential costs and
pick the ones you're going to be able to
deal with and I think this sort of
standard thing that's that's tended to
happen is for logistical reasons for
cost reasons for for bunch of reasons
typically most of the costs are are able
to be covered and some sort of a fewer
set of the benefits can be covered
that's about the technical problem at a
practical one and in this case the
benefits that were covered were to
carbon and something dude enhanced
biodiversity which isn't well circled
and I'll get into why it's something to
do with rather than exactly that and
then the set of cost management and the
opportunity cost in the area of
protected area benefits as I said to two
things two things calculated 11 the
value of avoided carbon emission
parameterised at seven dollars a ton and
that's that's the Serb prevailing price
at that time and perhaps now in the
voluntary market reduced by a 20-percent
buffer because that's what's happening
in these sorts of transactions that is
investor in one of these things wants to
be sure that even when you mess up by
some amount for how effective your
protected area is he still is getting
she still is getting her her money's
worth out of their carbon investment and
the second one something to do with
enhanced biodiversity the reason it's
something to do with is that that value
came from a willingness to pay study
conducted on residents of Sao Paulo for
their willingness to pay for the
continuation of a particular predicted
area mojado javo and and the motivations
that people gave varied they were
leisure air quality water research not
overlapping with carbon but not all
strictly sort of the non-use set either
so it's sort of hard to say what this
what this means other than etic that
it's probably a component and not
overlapping with the carbon component
and the methodology used to to take this
site number and extrapolate for the
broad area was very simply to assume
that people in this region are generally
about that willing to pay that much or
more to the point they may get at least
that amount to benefit from from New
predicted areas another assumption the
side of costs we looked at the two the
two obvious ones management costs which
is something like 750 per hectare per
year on the highest scale but these are
small predicted areas and a setup costs
up front we also liked an opportunity
cost for new areas a one-off timber cost
upfront to value of timber up front for
gone and that that's something like 250
dollars a hectare once and for the
opportunity cost of agricultural
production a weighted average of what's
currently in place in the landscape as
assumed to be taking as assumed to be
served taking hold in the new area that
would be de forested and the
profitability of those extrapolated in
as well I'm going to just sort of run
through how this stacks up and
attempting to be a little bit dramatic
by adding one and then the other but
that doesn't that's not logical it
doesn't have any sort of time sequence
to it it's just sorted to sort of
visualize how it lays out starting by
just adding in one echo system service
to what you'd otherwise think of as the
certain market values of the land timber
and pen
haag you get a straightforward sort of
result that carbon value exceeds that
that with carbon value that green snare
exceeds the value of the business is
usual scenario if you add back in
management costs business usual starts
to win and if you add back in this this
somewhat undefined bundle of good things
that people perceive as coming from
these protected areas as based on a
willingness to pay study again green
looks like a good choice for this region
maybe the interesting bit is to sort of
bring out some of the complexities and
doing this even though that looks serve
straightforward one of them would be to
note that management costs well it's a
cost is also something that benefits the
local economy some of it maybe most of
it not all perhaps goes to hire local
people goes to buy stuff from the local
economy and so it has to serve up here
in both columns another interesting
another interesting thing to consider is
that local value from agriculture may be
actually closer to the gross return than
the profit that is the standard
assumption would be to say the value of
Ag is the profit these guys earn this
much the rest is their cost but in fact
again many of those costs happen locally
those guys are buying your inputs
locally they're hiring people locally to
work in the farm and so on and that
suggests that those value should go up
as you as you as you try to do a better
job of this analysis the third point is
a key one and one that has served
repercussions throughout this but that
the negative welfare impact of carbon
emissions is much much higher than what
ends up being monetized in what sort of
exists already the voluntary market that
is the cost to society of each tonne of
carbon is much more than much being paid
now per ton and if you go with inflated
estimates from the stern report it's
something like thirty five dollars per
ton rather than seven or Defra I think
has a similar number and that's
important because that's a difference in
what society gets versus what what gets
locally even if a transaction happens
which isn't happening in most cases and
finally an error in this work that
that's worth noting is that go backwards
if you look at the carbon bar which is
the green one there is in fact carbon in
the AG landscape to
so that sort of principle of making sure
that you dealt with echo system services
and both landscapes was violated here
but anyway that's in the interest of
transparency so so just to show two more
sort of graphs of this if you start to
add in some of those considerations from
a local point of view you get a
different comparison if you if you had
in for example the increased actual
local value of economic activity from AG
and from payment and management thing
looks only marginally positive and that
again is only if someone's paying the
carbon if no one pays that that's a
theoretical value it's a value the world
would get it but the cost benefit of
this scale is negative and going to the
global scale you take instead of seven
bucks per ton 35 per ton and this thing
becomes whopping li+ carbon carbon is
sort of everyone's favorite elf in the
room in the room now and this is
probably partly why this plus a nation's
market and you get a positive a project
it looks like it has a quite a large
positive impact again the challenge is
getting the beneficiaries of these
things that are global to help share
some of that locally and this is this is
a point that I won't get into it but
discount rates obviously they're quite
relevant to these things as well just to
give one more example sort of on the
information side this is some work done
by colleagues in the science unit at CI
as well and what these guys did was to
look at across I think maybe four or
five countries people in and around
marine protected areas and asked a
couple of questions really do their
well-being I mean particular what their
income was and how diverse their income
was and something about perception as
well that I won't talk about but what
these guys found was if you take people
around protected areas in and around
protected areas and far from protected
areas the guys women the people near
predicted areas ended up fairly fairly
calm constantly and with a good good
confidence interval a good level of
confidence having a higher income and
having a more diverse income that that
isn't something to help you decide
anything beforehand in that place but
it's a lesson from one place that's
applicable per match to others and I
would just note that that again in the
interest of sort of transparency here
the full-blown matching
you haven't gotten to that yet other
sort of full-blown matching model that
that quantum and other people have used
for example in Costa Rica of picking
really matching people in terms of
access in terms of condition of the
resource beforehand wasn't done here so
there are potentially some
methodological points to again more to
illustrate what I think is a strong
finding more day lyst rated methodology
than the actual truth okay so in summary
then about information improved
information can among other things
suggest or provide inputs and do in to
where and if particular areas actually
makes sense and it can also inform
management strategies along the lines of
how to make predicted areas more
attractive to decision-makers the one
way to do that is through your
understanding trade-offs that is who's
giving up what as you take different
management strategies local use may be
really important and if you manage a
strict in a strict way that that goes
that's something to understand in a sort
of an intentional economic way and if
there are things like carbon that are
big piece of the value understanding the
market failure at play there and the
need to correct that as well if you want
to make conservation attractive locally
better information can also sort of
inspire management to manage to maximize
benefits and minimize costs there there
are things that can be done for example
to deal with crop rating that are
relatively low cost and have a huge
impact as far as both the costs felt
locally and probably open by the
effectiveness of areas based on better
relationships with people similarly in
regard to local benefits at
understanding sustainable local use can
be a big driver of permitting it again
possibility of retaining important
benefits important to note here is that
these are often logistical challenges
this isn't to say that sort of simple
economics should prevail and management
strategies but it's good information as
an input and finally there are a lot of
people that may or may not be moved by
saying this predicted area system this
investment is a good idea but clearly
that's the one audience for this kind of
thing um this sorry the second area of
market failure that I want to talk about
his issue of land and resource rights
and I'll really only talk about the
second point here but but I would note
that that enforcement is really key here
protected areas are like any sort of
property if you
and into them effectively you get you
get an irresponsible sort of a use over
the long term and I think the point I
wanted to bring out is that well that's
often seen as something that's against
local people's best interest I think
there's a huge role for improving
enforcement in tackling elites of
society whether those are served
privileged logging companies that know
someone in the police or big fishing
outfits that can set nets in places
other people aren't allowed to that
actually destroy resources that local
people might otherwise use sustainably I
think I wanted to flag the utility of
enforcement as a means to preserve the
long-term flow of benefits from
protected areas as again as with any
sort of form of property and the point
that I'll go into a little bit of detail
is this issue of recognition of local
rights and real participation and in
particular the possibility that can both
help create new kinds of protected areas
that serve multiple goals and also the
possibility that can help design more
effective sets of protected areas or
landscapes in fact that have a more
effective integration of different goals
in them and I'll talk very quickly
through two examples here the first is
is is and this is one of a lot of things
kind of like this is the southern guiana
community-owned conservation area which
is called a coca and that that in very
simple terms is a 600,000 hectare
community own community clared community
designed protected area which sits in a
country that has a very nascent
protected area system if it could be
called one at all and it's it functions
it's a real thing provides a model for
further community protected areas and
the point to bring out here is according
to the vision statement articulated by
these guys with help technical support
as they needed it was it this is a
protected area that has multiple goals
it serves multiple purposes and that and
it comes about from recognizing rights
and and including them in serve the
structure protected area design I won't
read it and I certainly won't read the
foreign language at the top the second
example I'll give you is actually also
not from a particular protected area
it's actually from a pulp concession in
Indonesia and it's it's one in which the
company that has a contention should get
credit here
go company and they sort of chose to do
this way beyond what the law at least
was requiring them to do and in
particular what they tried to do and
what we work with them on it was to
balance production and consistent
services and socio-cultural priorities
in their concession this is quite a sort
of a data heavy exercise and and so the
people involved started by generating
information on a koala logical
representation they started they were to
generate information on hydrology and
the reason this is important is because
this landscape floods that has
everything to do with what's culturally
important and where production is viable
culminating and flood mapping they
worked on production suitability and the
interesting thing here is that you can
model out across these landscapes where
a production might be most important and
there are places in this landscape that
aren't good for production that's
important to know too and they worked on
community priorities and there is always
fun to show sort of community priority
maps and I resisted the temptation to do
that but but the idea here too is that
where there's quite a heavy process of
consultation to understand what
communities use for what where and why
and what they what they envisioned as
their own sort of future use this area
and the really the really sort of useful
part of this I think is that clearly you
can't take a bunch of data layers and
just kind of slap them on top of each
other and have the right answer come out
the end they need to work on some way to
integrate that stuff and integrate what
are in effect multiple objectives for
the same landscape and so that the
decision hierarchy in this case is
interesting and that it represents
objectives from all the different
perspectives from biodiversity
representation point of view the idea
was to me TECA logical representation
targets and maintain hydrological
function this this idea of minimizing
shape within spatial characteristics had
to do with not having things that were
sort of long and sneaky and minimize the
number of individual tiny protected
spots from a production standpoint
simply the idea is to minimize the cells
rated for rated high for production that
go into the conservation area from a
community perspective three bits one is
to maximize the amount of community use
land two is to conserve sacred sites and
three and this is interesting I think it
to exclude villages from the
conservation area and that that was
based on interest in having the jobs
that would come from
factories and so what you get if you do
this and you go through a process of
serve multi-criteria analysis and
understanding different objectives is
the potential to maximize areas that are
important for ecological function
representation and community in
particular in the less productive areas
and just to explain this map of it this
is the concession in fact and lots of
different chunks because that's how I
was granted with production suitability
and green high mid production
productivity suitability and yellow and
low suitability of blue and going
through this process came up with a
protected area system that looks like
this that is the areas in black and you
probably can't tell but I'll officer
toggle back and forth and and the what
what in fact happened was that the
generation of a map of potential
predicted areas that that really was by
and large on the low on the low
production areas so much so that the
company is willing now to explore even
more conservation conservation area
again an opportunity to to include local
perspectives in the design um and I can
talk more about that too among other
things as I go along anyway so in
summary about this point addressing
rights and participation can can among
other things provide at least a
foundation for addressing equity again
sort of have input into where and if
protected areas are good choice and for
whom and for whom they should be a good
choice they can inform management
strategies a great potential source
energy in management strategy I think
they can open the door to multiple types
of protected areas being created with
multiple objectives and I think that
they importantly also can simply improve
the delivery of services through
improved effectiveness better community
relationships not cutting people off
from key sources of income and things
like that and that this isn't all sort
of a bit of roses obviously when you get
down to it but there's potential for
this to work and to be important um the
final sort of market failure i'll i'll
talk about a bit is again the issue of
externalities and public goods and i
think the challenge here is a simple one
in theory and a hard nut to crack in
reality and it is to increase the share
of costs paid by beneficiaries and you
can do that at every scale from local to
global theoretically and these are some
of the possible ways to do it and and
create
they also to make sure that the people
that are in a position to choose to
provide or not those positive
externalities get some of the incentive
to do it and it's important to
disaggregate that that is it's not
enough to for example make a rent
payment to Peru and and be done there
may be as long as the government of Peru
is allocating that money to the right
sort of incentive structure to its
people it's not like it's not purely a
question of the government proves
incentive and that's not the singer I'll
approve that's that's a constant thing
to make sure that the particular people
bearing the costs the particular people
with a choice between deforestation to
not get there get the get to share in
the benefits of not doing it I'll
straight this with with with 1k swelled
with two cases but one is fairly simple
this one is a case from Kenya its work
done by a couple of partners and it's
one exit that Pavano is involved in and
can talk about if that's useful this is
a context that's trying to conserve
Lions water and forest and the sort of
basic dynamic here is that people are
herders in this landscape and lions
traditionally are a net cost to people
they kill livestock and they provide
relatively little benefit communities
have not traditionally shared very much
and tourism benefit and that's that's
what Lions might be good for so the sort
of generic starting point in this
landscape might be something like this
that is although conservation is
attractive globally it isn't locally and
the reason is because the majority of
what happens locally is this cost of
lions killing livestock and people don't
share information the benefits the
national scale is important benefits and
tourism there's important benefits in
water and some costs perhaps paid in
protected area management the global
scale there there are things like the
existence of lions and these amazing
landscapes around Kilimanjaro that have
a value but again at that scale there's
almost no sharing of costs so what these
guys are doing is starting to address
some of the market failures that relate
to that benefit and cost distribution
and in particular to I've been when
they've worked on traditionally one of
them is tourism practices working to
hire more people to pay better wages and
that's something that increased their
costs and increases the benefit locally
the other thing they've been working on
is trying to capture some some of the
global interest in the existence of this
landscape people animals Kilimanjaro all
that stuff
and get it in a very concrete form to
local people and the way they've been
doing that is through supporting this
thing called predator compensation
that's an in effect an insurance scheme
for local people so that if their
livestock are killed they get by a lion
they can receive the value of the
livestock killed as long as no one's
been killing Lions a sort of a
straightforward arrangement but one that
gets the incentive to the right place
then again these are hypothetical
numbers the sort of balance may be
different at the local scale with this
intervention alone but but just is
mostly to illustrate the point what's
going on now is an attempt to add other
things into that mix in particular to
add the benefit that that's felt in
parts of the country from water
protected by these by this area and
potentially get them to pay if they can
pay the national actors will increase
their cost or the water users in
particular local benefit will go up
again and potentially to get some some
of the carbon market everyone's dream
again to provide some benefit nationally
and some locally and the story is sort
of the straightforward one right if all
of these things come together or some
set of them do conservation becomes
attractive locally which it already is
even without some of these things but
there's some sustainability challenges
and as a result people choose not to
degrade the ecosystem that use not the
poison lions which is a ridiculously
easy thing to do and as a result
everybody's better off people investing
in the public good got the problem good
to be conserved and and again sort of
standard economics prevails everyone
ends up better off but the sort of last
example I'll give about this is is it's
from Peru and it's in fact sort of an
attempt to deal with multiple market
failures in one place it is an example
from the alto mile protected forest
which is this beautiful hilly area in
San martín it's about 400 thousand
hectares it's critical for biodiversity
it's also the most threatened national
predicted area in Peru and that's
because people live right inside of it
and there's a huge amount of pressure on
its borders and until fairly recently
not a huge commitment to protect it
we're not a huge ability to protect him
and the sort of strategy to deal with
that can be conceptualized and put into
whatever language is right but one way
to do that might be to think of it as
the various market market failures that
they're addressing it is now conceived
of as a red project is in the past been
conceived as a particular effectiveness
project or a conservation group proj
but what's at play now is sort of first
and as the big sort of most visible
thing a red plus project something
funded by the Disney Corporation and
that is that is in effect an attempt to
internalize the positive externality of
avoided emissions to get the local
people that would admit to share the
benefit of not emitting and to change
their decision-making that way the
second bit of this is to provide
technical support for sustainable coffee
another agriculture potentially and
there are possibly to market failures
that play there 11 is both information
failures what one is the simple failure
of good technical information to get to
people that's not an environmental
failure just a failure there are good
things to do that are kind of neutral
for the environment but much good much
better for production and the other and
this is when we're investigating is
whether consumers are going to be
willing to pay more for sending our
genes coffee if they know it's not
deforesting places like that val tamayo
the third air here is to improve
governance and law enforcement that's an
issue of dealing with property rights
the government hasn't traditionally be
able to enforce its property rights that
results in in the classic problem of
some people the less law-abiding perhaps
not always moving into this area
trafficking in land that that's at the
cost to the whole population of that of
that region and finally the issue of
conservation agreements which is where
this was before rid came onto the scene
and those are quite simply a mechanism
in which a quid pro quo mechanism in
which we offer we we in this case
honestly we have been offering some
benefit in exchange for community making
some commitment to conservation in this
case a commitment not to clear in
exchange for a technical support for
agriculture that is basically just a
contract mechanism to ensure a quid pro
quo pro quo with communities and channel
sort of whatever public good payment is
is available we've done those for water
which is less of a public good and
mostly we've been trying to capture
individuals or foundations that
represent individuals that benefit from
the from the existence of biodiversity
and as I mentioned that's a sort of a
sustainability challenge on top of
everything else so in summary then
addressing externalities and public
goods problems can I think basically do
this a simple thing if you could get it
to happen which would be to make
conservation attractive to
decision-makers where it would be in the
public good
but it isn't now in their local interest
and if you do that you will undoubtedly
increase area under protection you'll
improve management you'll address some
equity issues but to make it happen
obviously you have to crack the same nut
of public goods problems that you know
that are the definition of why they
don't get solved in the first place um
just take a deep breath for a second
this is the last part okay um so I
thought I'd I just sort of closed by
offering some final thoughts of two
kinds want a bit more general and that
is I think as we think about using these
sorts of tools it's very important to be
honest about the generation of economic
arguments for protected areas i think
the world you know especially in the
wake of teeb is quite open to this sort
of stuff but at least in many of the
developing countries the quality of data
available is pretty poor and people are
willing to accept fairly rough analysis
I and in particular for example that
issue of total benefit versus marginal
benefits one that often gets confused
and so I think I think it's quite
important to be clear about what we're
producing and be clear about it to
decision makers even if it's a bit more
complex because otherwise I think things
are going to come around and bite us and
we'll be accused of sort of snake oil
sales over time I think that's a mistake
um and there are real human human
consequences to selling that snake oil
if it's not true the second issue is
somewhat obviously to consider rights
and distribution issues and site and
management choices is a huge scale for
just understanding this thing or huge
scope for doing that to inform site
choices for example the third point
would be would be to make sure to look
across the full suite of market failure
is that that classic example of assuming
that information is the answer but
really it being a problem of not having
people paying for what they're sharing
in the benefit of is an area that
continues to go on there's there's a
huge efforts devotee that information
without understanding what degree of the
problem that actually is in a given
place and so I would say in particular
it's key to be aware of what incentives
are at play in the landscapes we're
dealing with that's a distribution
question among others
and the final point in this bit I think
and this might almost be the foundation
of this all is to keep an eye out for
four cases where the public good isn't
the objective of decision makers so so
all of these sort of generate arguments
that say if you created this protected
area here and somebody shared a benefit
with somebody else and you manage this
way society would be better off the
local people would have a better
livelihood the country would protect its
natural heritage in the world would gain
some carbon but but very often maybe
every where that isn't how
decision-makers are making their
decisions they're making decisions based
on who their friends are based on their
sort of worldview based on
constituencies and all of those things
but you know the classic example is
being the massive amount of subsidies
that go in all sorts of funny directions
that are clearly aren't in the public
good and are bad investments of scarce
government money but they happen anyway
so it's good I think as we think about
sort of choosing to generate economic
arguments to understand who we think
we're going influence and whether
they're going to care because they're
quite a lot of places where we could
waste some good bullets going down this
path the second sort of bit of the final
thoughts here is to talk a bit about my
sort of take on what might be some
priority areas for technical work going
forward I think one of the key areas
here is somewhat obviously to work in
this area of rigorous cost-benefit
analysis that is what would be the
marginal increase or decrease in service
flow if we spend a marginal amount more
or less in what kind of protected area
management and what would be the change
in the other kinds of values coming from
that area if we did that that kind of
nuanced and high quality analysis is
very scarce there probably maybe I maybe
you guys know more the current source
data dissing idea but there probably ten
studies that have done that that's not
nearly enough to make any sort of
general conclusion it's not one per
country it's not serve representative of
different biomes and it's an area in
which I think rigor in making this kind
of argument is really needed and it
would add to the servitor over all of
our ability to say these sorts of things
um the second point is i think i think
that the sort of expression of a lot of
this stuff addressing market failures in
particular can find itself
in trying to to to roll out multiple
sort of coordinated invent interventions
in a particular landscape or perhaps an
economic sector and what I mean by that
is is generating enough technical input
to understand where you might put
protected areas how we might manage them
so that service flows for example go
down downstream to people who pay the
people upstream and we think about where
we're we're going to support what kind
of viable economic activities that
people are not drawn near the protected
area and various serve flows of payment
go to make the making sense of structure
at work and that that to that sort of
landscape level planning including the
protected area component requires a
technical basis to start and also to
manage over time a thing would be would
be to try to crack this problem of sort
of increasing cost sharing on existence
value in particular but on public goods
I that's something we played around with
we've made some progress and so of
others the carbon market certainly is a
fantastic intriguing possibility if it
emerges for one of those values but
existence has all reason continues to
plague conservation groups something in
which is obvious that increased global
spending makes a ton of sense and in
which increased global spending for
things like recurring management haven't
have not materialized the fourth area
here would be would be to to think about
how we can integrate this into the green
economy movement I think that there's a
huge role for thinking about market
failure as one of us are addressing
market failure is one of those sort of
hallmarks of why a green economy might
make sense and finally this is sort of a
caveat like the one in the first of
these slides the the history the
documented history with good data of
better information or better flows of
payments changing behavior is poorly
understood and we're certainly in sort
of new territory and thinking about how
we can rule out really good economic
analyses like these to change behavior
about resources to change behavior
within protected areas and what that
will do to service flow change what
they'll do a service flows and so I
would say that as we do this is a great
role for simply being conscious probably
test hypotheses and how we learn from
what we're doing and that that too is
there for technical work I think um
and that's the end so I think the idea
is that there will be questions now i'm
happy to answer whatever one's have come
up thanks